indiana
extends that defense lobbit catch it
no foul and rudy and turner get into it
go hit the deck
and now we got problems oh
not good
not good go bear you could just sense it
coming t
and you've got security
trying to separate the pacers and the
jazz more than one player now getting
involved
donovan mitchell's hot
[Applause]
boy donovan's still going at it
there's a lot that happened when most of
the team
were on their way down
[Applause]
here we go in real time
right here really wanted that foul was
frustrated it was over the top and you
gotta you gotta ask and the officials
may as well and here's the aftermath a
little chess bump and a wrestling match
underway five plays under review for
hostile act
well yeah it's a hostile act no question
but i wonder if you see the replay again
is that's an aggressive
foul yes
the retaliation right here there's the
push and then the the bear hug and the
takedown
joe gets in it
conley's trying to be a peacemaker and
donovan gets hot and it took some time
because
you know the three officials and eight
players
were already on